[Musique]
des décombres encore fumantes voici tout
ce qu'il reste de ces maisons en
banlieue de Kiev a pris la salve russe
de ce jeudi matin
les frappes ont résonné jusqu'au
centre-ville où les habitants se sont
réfugiés dans le métro
tout ça on ne sait pas combien de temps
la guerre va encore durer c'est
difficile d'avoir peur tous les jours et
de mettre sa vie entre parenthèses
il y a eu des explosions très fortes
c'était proche en fait ce matin c'était
vraiment fou
à coup de missiles et de drone la Russie
continue de frapper les infrastructures
de l'Ukraine privant les habitants
d'électricité
à vivre dans l'ouest du pays les
transports ont été stoppés net
il n'y a pas de courant je suis désolé
je ne peux vraiment pas vous donner de
délai on repartira quand l'électricité
sera revenue les dégâts auraient pu être
encore plus important l'armée
ukrainienne se félicite d'avoir
intercepté en vol la plupart des
missiles tirés par la Russie
a lancé une frappe massive sur le
territoire ukrainien visant des
infrastructures vitales énergétiques
dans les régions de l'est du centre de
l'ouest et du sud de notre pays l'ennemi
attiré plus de 69 missiles la défense
aérienne de notre pays on a détruit 54
dans le même temps un missil Ukrainien
se serait écrasé en Biélorussie selon
les autorités de ce pays alliés de
Moscou depuis le début de l'offensive
russe en Ukraine c'est la première fois
qu'un incident de ce type est rapporté
en territoire biélorus